hey how are you bernzy what's shakin I
had no idea cuz I like all the guys in
the cellar like Sam you I think you're a
great all right well no we we know now
with the first couple years Wow I see
yeah we'd have meetings about it that
unit is probably awkwardness it's
probably just social did you really like
sit there for years when Jim wasn't
around just talk about like no I think
Jim hates me more than Jim he all the
time
why start with a tell then you meet Jim
than you think about Jim why why are you
saying that they give the impression
they had everyone yeah like you just
assumed they hate you
I've only been here five days and I'm
leaving before I cry yeah telling me
that the guy he thought I didn't like
like I think mark is really funny and I
think sama like Mac T all those guys are
hilarious but you can think somebody's
funny and hate them but I don't hate
anything my life very much no but it's
not it's also your and weirdness and our
weirdness colliding you know yeah it's I
can I am a socially very odd person like
you get to the point like I'm not
comfortable with anyone yes you only not
being comfortable you're sure well also
this place is so busy New Yorker so
there's so much input all the time yeah
that like you just [ __ ] stop blinking
yeah and like you're not sleep yeah
sometimes you get to a gym doesn't stop
like I haven't been to bed out yeah Jim
have you been to bed in a day and a half
maybe maybe 48 you can see it's not
actually the city that never sleeps
everybody yeah you can tweet off you bye
yeah my body [ __ ] up as well yeah all
from Austria are you are you living in
England or I live in the UK in UK coming
I solved the new the New York puzzle
what I said like you like I wasn't quite
communicating properly in New York and I
did Sherrod how great blog is Sherrod
that's right it's like if you drop a
name - crowd cheers or or boos yeah
depending oh really oh did I pick the
fights yeah dodge and Sandy came but I
didn't realize I am because I have to
suffer my accent when I'm here otherwise
Latino people kind of know right
right Latinos but the thing is in the UK
I'm a [ __ ] kicker I'm like white trash
[ __ ] scumbag uh-huh and I did sure
odds race Wars yesterday and I did not
represent myself well at all why well
because I do a podcast that's like sure
odds but the the premise of the podcast
is I'm a [ __ ] idiot it's called dumb
white guy and it's I interviewed comics
of different ethnicity sexuality and
gender and I asked dumb white guy
questions right so we were being
introduced it then comes around to me
and he goes introduce yourself I said I
Brennan burns I host um white guy I do
the version of this show but it's
educated right okay and everyone's like
clearly it took us an hour to clear it
up he's where I am from it is
preposterous for me to talk like that
and I knew that it's so obvious it's
like your theme song you were just
joking being sarcastic and being silly
and I feel like a [ __ ] where ya from
I'm almost punching up half the time
sure so but here I sound like [ __ ]
Kikuyu England yeah you got that British
so I got the [ __ ] swagger of the
Aussie bloke with his [ __ ] guard up
I'm like so like my demeanor everybody
by the way most people assume it's a
British accent yes I guess from your
perspective it's almost like imagine a
jason Ellis that thinks he's better than
you are intuitive to me because
everything I do is anti snobbery right
oh no I can't stand [ __ ] puffed-up
pompous [ __ ]
oh so it's so counterintuitive that it
took us 45 minutes I'm superior realised
that so a joke
maybe you're stretching first I've had
those little things reminds me of a
Three's Company episode where Jack said
something mr. Furley thought he was a
homosexual yeah standing I put a
lampshade on my head we gots The Vicar I
knocked off a [ __ ] guy yeah so it's
uh there's been a lot of talking across
purposes as I said but well so who that
was so helpful who do you think hates
you though here
Booker's oh yeah mark
I think I rub pit no I think I rub
people and audiences up the wrong way
really that's all I have to give them a
leading like it worked at the Patrice
benefit where I went all right I'm a
[ __ ] scumbag uh-huh I'm not yeah you
know to you I sound like I'm off Downton
Abbey right but I'm in Australian that's
based in the UK I'm like this got love
for the credits II don't like three
rungs below a black guy uh-huh
in terms of socially like it's a anytime
I'm hanging out with like a white
English kid half my [ __ ] age it's a
countdown to when they go like oh you're
actually quite clever and I'm like go
get me a [ __ ] coffee right
like that's not alpha that's not our
dynamic your snooty [ __ ] all right
but so having to deal with that all the
time then come in here Oh naturally then
having to undo that yeah I see it's
complicated for you
well you don't you worry about who cares
yeah just tell your dirty jokes and
that's why Aryan and DeRosa was so
helpful and wonderful re-enter osa re re
and the white power Joe exactly but yeah
he came and watch my set and just said
just slow down do it like you you're in
Europe it was funny I went on after Joe
at the benefit he had a funny here too
good set mine you should see his latest
ow no really check it out no I don't
want anyone's stuff doesn't my love the
roaster but I gotta go watch his stuff
yeah you know watch Chris Rock special
you're gonna watch Joe DeRosa space
great point which anybody I gotta say I
saw Mulaney at the Radio City was
unbelievable unbelievable area he's like
the next guy I don't know how he's on a
household name this is gonna put him on
a map but since my and John Mulaney is
[ __ ] hilarious brilliant when you see
something like that do you go like this
is awesome or do you go like [ __ ] I'm
not there a little about yeah it's good
that there's that level of comedy out
there but you're still like I could
never do that right and then I had to go
do a spot at the stand with eight people
and I died a bad set yeah it was just
like I just couldn't get there and they
weren't into it was
as a whole what's your version of dying
you know just titters and nut a little
laughs that seems like universal dying
yeah yeah yeah quiet quiet room yeah
stop in Scotland so it's like bottles
getting beaten up maybe boot off and so
well I don't one clapped me enough Wow
yeah I mean I don't think today the
bombing is silenced
yeah bombing is silent that's all the
way I'm surrounded by like three of the
greatest voices in radio how much do I
sound like a [ __ ] [ __ ] you mix a
great voice he's an old school radio guy
I clear my throat all the time and he's
got a nice professional childlike voice
seriously honey tones everywhere
Sammy bran muffins that's right atm
[Laughter]
Oh DAF in a good way
[Laughter]
they're hearing it I swear to god you
pull that I throw and I'm deaf and Jim
thought he pulled out so like hello you
mean deaf
so I yell at sorry yell at people like I
was with DeRosa at the Gotham and the
guy came out the the manager normal
something and my hearing aid was playing
up cuz [ __ ] New York so noisy they're
battered mm-hm and I didn't even
introduce myself and I first was out of
my mouth the poor guys my deaf [ __ ]
check slot was loud he's like hello I'm
mark or whatever is there is a neurosis
like as a British guy which didn't do me
any favor
no is Brandon he's a British guy when
did you go deaf at the age of seven man
meningitis and then I didn't know got
diagnosed in 2013 and I've listened back
to all old albums now [ __ ] unbearable
so see you I see you you're kind of you
can hear but it's all [ __ ] up and you
didn't know until recent
missing 30 decibels in each year so how
many what percentage are you of hearing
what percentage could you hear well
we've decibels a weed as well apparently
right so like say if we had like a
volume turn up to 40 and you took 30 off
it there wouldn't actually be 3/4 mm-hmm
off right it's a cumulative with you
know I mean I think it's as it goes up
why I'll add that last 10 yeah 30 to 40
is a lot more than 1 to 10 in terms of a
difference in how loud something weight
but I think it's the other way around
yeah it's the oh I wish I was deaf the
other one white guy of all people should
know how decibels work you should
because the rest of us just hear well I
mean I we found out I was deaf at the
UFC gentle sherrod the Rose all this
name drop it's almost like sometimes
when you go to places you want to it
like a name like local references so you
go like so I got here on route 66 hey
that's a rodent race we found out it was
my wife and I at the Chael Sonnen
Anderson silver rematch having talked
it's so much [ __ ] about Brazil yeah yeah
so it's I think so yeah that's spinning
backfist and he fell and he lost a
second round yes yes yes didn't you
didn't recognize me you are throwing
banana all over the goddamn place it's
fine we got a whole staff to take care
of stuff like that why would you shove
your mouthful of banana in the middle of
a story that's the benefit I'm gonna
have my hand held a bit short version of
the story so he need a shot about dazeem
in the chin
and the place goes [ __ ] great right
there all booing all right they're all
screaming at the top of their lungs
Brazilian fans American fans just at the
weigh-in and and then Rogan goes to
interview him and his [ __ ] deafening
and my wife goes oh don't don't start
you know Yellin while he's interviewing
him I can't make any of this out and I'm
looking up at the big monitor and I when
he said ciao doesn't respect my country
doesn't respect the UFC and tomorrow
fight and then both my wife and I looked
at one another jaw-dropping like how
that did I and the fact that I make that
out like I cut because it's so pitch
affected as well sure I can't hear you
or my son if you're in the next room and
my wife said verbatim she goes that's
because he the only man in this building
that his trained is hearing to negotiate
the sound of one man laughing in a room
full of people booing that's when we
found out I could lip-read and then I
got to test it and then you can lip-read
but you didn't know you've got only a
context but that's how like the
audiologist said do you stand near the
front first of all he goes is it loud at
your work and I said apparently when I'm
on and then he goes do you stand at the
front all the time and like ask him to
turn on the first three lights so you
can see the first three rows said yeah
you said that's so you can tell how you
doing you've been deficit said
interesting yeah but like like partial
hearing I should say right obviously I
could you you you ask them to turn the
lights up so you can see yeah see the
lips the last thing I want to see yeah
yeah and so I used to always like really
like it was all like I said I listen
back to it now it's [ __ ] unbearable
it's all OneNote screaming just back and
it's deafening and I can't listen to it
punch myself in the face
so you should use is like a gimmick I
mean it's a good thing and stand-up you
have a thing
III didn't brochure about it sorry I'm
genetic or Brendan burns isn't heard of
you either and it's five reasons you've
never heard of me and the reason number
one was I yell and I swear uh-huh I mean
woman you didn't work in the fact that
you can't hear you should do five
reasons the Brendan burns has never
heard of you exactly yeah all right cuz
you can't [ __ ] hear five songs
someone talks it all kind of went in the
that's how Cabana and I met Cole Cabana
annoy we do a comedy wrestling show
together
every year but he was a plant in that
show ah in a guy in a wheelchair with
the gunner wheelchair this really is
like a comedy wrestling show like you do
in restaurants the funny thing is the
more twists you put and the more
distractions you put the less people
will know it's like the bigger the lie
the more people will believe yes I see
hmm
so it was my mate Barry in a wheelchair
and I pretended that he was a guy that I
used to work with when I was doing
social services in Australia in Perth
Western Australia called Billy a moss
and it's actually my friend Barry caster
NOLA because he was pretending to be
special and then I get into a fight with
his carer and everyone kind of panics
and then cabana
I'm beginning to that that was the day
that cabana was coming to see the show
he get stands up and acts really well
and throws the guy out of the room and
says that that guy's a wrestler they
tear their clothes off they're wearing
wrestling tights they get into a fight
and the funniest thing is every day so
many bells and whistles no one ever
looked at they left at Barry in the
wheelchair and went wait a minute look
if there what about him because there
was so much going on right and the show
ended with him getting up out of the
wheelchair walking and then smashing me
over the head with [ __ ] a balsa wood
plank and [ __ ] me I should have got
proper balsa wood because it didn't rank
every night and then [ __ ] it whatever
happened to jokes you know what you do a
month on the trot like particularly the
Edinburgh Festival you need like time to
reset something mix it up because no
matter what at some point you're not
going to hit it wrong so what happened
at the at the Patrice benefit was it
mainly jokes or was it was it
shenanigans uh retail what kind of main
to one another okay I kind of like
everyone chatter boss yeah I do see any
of that III I regrettably made a comment
I'd he was dressed like the toddler of
an ms-13
[Laughter]
yeah but he's a six-year-old Jew in
Jordan because it's quite jarring how
much if one does rice here right yeah
when you when you're raised on UK peace
eNOS and is it bad over there
oh yeah the worse than life but it's
also not coming from a good place oh
it's nudie it's kind of classist
interesting and so that's why when you
first come to New York and you're like
go away I mean this is a bit [ __ ]
racist but then you look around the room
and you realize oh everyone's in right
is every right where's in the UK it's
like their version of discussing races
you know that nigel Faraj is a racist
hey man we're good and then you look
around the room and it's nothing but
middle-class white pages well people do
that here like yeah you know that's like
college kids and stuff yeah is that here
it's just you're hanging out with New
York comics saying that that's crosses
all borders people who are full of it so
you were you nervous about the Patrice
benefit because you know you got and you
got all these comics that are like they
know each other very well you're kind of
the odd man out but you're friends with
Patrice but they don't all know that
right were you friends with Patrice yeah
we met in 98 I was one of five people in
the UK he could tolerate Wow
yeah that's Chuck and I think you don't
get any more beers you know Gavin his
friend Gavin big EV huh no don't a big
gaff Jimmy Curtis he's no he's not a
comedians name is Gavin he's just a big
guy that hang on but recently he might
have he's a giant guy they didn't have
many friends there no or here giant
there's not a blog to take home to meet
the missus yeah no he wasn't
oh I got a story for you okay so I get a
coffee
I'm joking oh hey baby all right here
the Patrice story nice long
I heard you told the story at the
benefit I did so it went quite overtime
a little bit oh yeah what happened was I
didn't meet glasses don't do comedians
like that for me I didn't notice it
sneaks out that was scowling at me oh
yeah everybody said the foreign guy went
long they don't like that when people go
especially the outsider right comes in
out of nowhere
people are talking I don't have an
anti-glare on a minute look [ __ ] so you
can't see her here so I looked up there
yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah and I looked up
and then the time had gone now [ __ ] I
didn't dude I wanted to tell a story
particularly because it was a story I
knew no one hurt but did you tell it
anyway and I want to tell the story they
went yeah yeah [ __ ] Maureen Lauren
cannot tell a story and then Voss ran
out when I'm giving you permission to do
a story that's true he has no authority
yeah because I guess as a comic when
you're looking at somebody on stage and
he's already gone over his time yeah and
then he acknowledges it and goes to the
audience I got a Patrice story do you
want to hear it what are they gonna say
are you guys backstage gonna be like
kunti course manipulation yes well
that's it kind of was it's like when you
say to the audience all right guys
they're telling me I gotta go even if he
doesn't do the story he gets off then
the next comic goes up and the audience
is like we wanted to hear that story he
talked about yeah I look up and I
thought I saw three minutes so in [ __ ]
times gone right and I don't really have
much of a inner monologue onstage I
don't do a lot of thinking uh-huh just
hear or see your thing
and I sound [ __ ] snooty wallet like a
knife yes the time doesn't help so you
tell the story anyway I tried to tell it
as quick as I can yes I do it and the
funny thing was like it got like
applause breaks in places I wasn't
expecting right now it's already fall
not from the other comics pretty risky
that was the thing I think DeRosa now
realize in hindsight was [ __ ] with me
right because I said to a couple of guys
you telling Patrice stories right no and
one puts you're a gang isn't this your
safest and then DeRosa said he started
the story but then bailed on and he goes
can you imagine right like it's 90%
chance it's gonna go well but that 10%
and if you bomb at that gig no I'm never
gonna be allowed to live it down
and I was like you can't what do you
well I guess I'm getting on a plane so
it doesn't matter right true but but
this was your one shot like you're very
excited familiar with the audience like
this is your shot for that audience to
be like I don't know who this guy is
sure you win him over
we get to see a lot a lot of more of him
than the other comics for this story
yeah you were gone I was I didn't bother
me I was gone so you know over time
nothing minutes I heard I heard you did
29 how's the Patrice benefit they said
Jessica garrison killed and some British
guy went 30 minutes lies I'm just
telling you what I heard three minutes I
burned I was doing 10 29 [ __ ] mangoes
all right I'm right now checked himself
sure yeah [ __ ] your pakka
[ __ ] mango I'm texting right now you
girls felt taken advantage of because
the foreign guy came on and did 30 when
he's made for waiting six [ __ ] years
and tell him one story haven't heard oh
I didn't realize it was the Brendan
burns benefit
terrified babies through your goddamn
ten minutes and go home right mark yeah
yeah what were they scared of you saying
they're terrified what were they
terrified of odo sir was saying like so
there's that 10% if it doesn't go oh
yeah we'll never let each other down I'm
like you mean you don't let each other
file you [ __ ] cat ha ha ha oh my god
no he wanted you to do it yeah yeah he
said you've got to do it yeah I think
you think a year from now I'm not used
to playing a two and a half thousand
seat theater I can see why you think
next year at the Patrice benefit people
are gonna be backstage being like you
remember that [ __ ] British guy that
went through it that's great that's
gonna last forever
yes no what happened at all so that
thing where like you're never gonna live
it down if you bomb same thing happens
if you go over like sure 30 minutes oh
yeah the comedians will love you if you
go over the comedians will hate you
that's why give you bombed the comments
will enjoy it oh dude that was awesome
hang on let's go to Christa teacher on
line one because Christa teacher was at
the show called boss how funny are you
listeners boy hello Chris you brought
out a black guy because it was a nimble
minute because it was Patrice as a
Nimbus I see did you ask him permission
first they did you tell Greer you're
gonna do that so now your stalkers gonna
do that okay and did he go long did he
go long Chris do you think okay so
here's the here's the debate Chris
Christopher you think why is this like
one of your list of things this like I
got a [ __ ] on the garda get in no oh
yeah so Chris Brendan is saying he went
13 minutes which means he went over
they [ __ ] time
is saying that rumor has it that it was
closer to 29 minutes that's what I heard
I find 29 little hard yeah my kid clock
shut the [ __ ] up
well 27 years I've been doing this
monkey clock I in that [ __ ] Chris what
do you think with all due respect to
mark Normand who I love it was probably
about 15 minutes 15 you've now done
you've now done 50% extra time becomes
15 that's 50% exercise thank you very
much appreciate nice oh my god I hate
that that's what that looks like cuz
there's a guy in in England called Peter
Kay who goes on in the middle Peter K I
know that name yeah he's a bit of a
thief he's a bit of a continent the
benefit next year he's even stole from
his friends who when they rang him up
and said what are you doing you're doing
my bit he just like hung up and never
spoke to them again is he the guy he the
one tour recently but he didn't yes
that's it
he's a very famous comic someone said
they don't have a year's worth of gigs
sold and then totally canceled the tour
due to illness or something I think his
mom died they used to go on in the
middle and he used to do the thing of
our look folks I'd stay on forever but I
gotta go
they've got to get another act on the
story I go back and choked up because
you've all had time to process at I
haven't even when I was in here the
other day right a bit bittersweet any
time [ __ ] it's cause I haven't thought
about for ages I've got a [ __ ] lump
in my throat and then Rosa was so funny
[ __ ] on me yesterday he goes because
I didn't went backstage and just [ __ ]
pursed into tears and them in the wings
just like just sobbed like a big girl's
blouse like hid where no one can see me
and there's funny then DeRosa comes up
goes are you crying like so disgusted
yeah and then Sam Jay gave us a bit of a
hug and then
DeRosa then like gives it
a 24-hour [ __ ] respite and then like
on race Wars yesterday he goes Masaki
people didn't speak to you afterwards
because [ __ ] faking some tears to get
like take over the [ __ ] and tears on
stage to get extra points yeah I choked
and I [ __ ] I started to get a bit
lumpy like I did in here the other night
also bearing in mind as well I'm not
sleeping a lot while I me yeah I'm a bit
more showing you don't say no normally
would ya understandable talking about
that with you yes yes sorry even when I
was in here the other day and I was
trying to tell the story and I've got a
lump in me throat right and and so then
I started to tell that and it's funny
that I've never had an audience hold my
hand before mm-hmm where people were
like go on [ __ ] right yeah why you
did all your tricks this time to get
them absolutely folks are telling me I
gotta go if the comic before me says
they lie they got to get another act on
that's not a guy that does that way
would be telling when he did that
yes crushing and then you say give it up
for the troops I bet when grit barn said
the N word the place went nuts
absolutely absolutely I'm seeing a black
guy out to say it and get away with
awesome that kills well I just didn't
well you know what Bill Maher's giving
himself a pass just cuz he vote Democrat
that's why I backed away like I used to
have like five jokes that had it in it
oh yeah I only do it in a serious
statement discussing politics which is
strange because my wife's Chinese so I
don't feel comfortable doing that just
because it feels a bit like too many
people for sure yeah or affording
themselves the past it's almost like in
our stuffs becoming so ironic that it
becomes face value now sure like your
theme song yes I'm gonna soar on it that
it's face value it's right and we're
almost an ironic well it's just a happy
song to have you guys the only thing
that I [ __ ]
since me as they're up at the end
because I'm like what I don't need that
bridge yes like that happy morning's
yeah British you get you like give us
credit listen to how funny your
listeners are right like week one okay
hey Amy out right demon Sam like a
[ __ ] radio blah blah zoo where wacky
right and then cut to jim gun you know
mango makes [ __ ] [ __ ] come tastes
good right the juxtaposition is there we
don't we don't need a hand biology does
so the I know what you're saying but it
was only a little uh it wasn't crazy
like yeah the bridge was so small I
didn't mind I think I even caught it the
first time and just like that we
fine-tune I don't mind either one I'm
okay with it I like that I like the
because it's a wink yeah right actually
because actually I now given that I now
have to say in Australia I'm a scumbag
I'm not posh I so when I say this [ __ ]
I'm not looking down my nose at you
right it's just thinking I'm trying to
have to do that it's at the end okay
take it back off yeah alright wait to
meet chip
Oh chip that's you and I were talking
across purposes the first time we met
cuz I you weren't doing chip yet and
what are we doing chip
what did you say but do you meet chip
wait till you meet chip chip person yes
I don't yeah man the common person why
are you diamondden you know I don't like
to break the fourth wall oh no am I
talking to the man behind the curtain
no I don't know what he's talking about
there well now what do you mean when was
this so we talked I was when I came any
first time with Foley and maybe that's
right yeah nice yeah we did I do like
wrestling comedy shows with him sometime
huh and but you would facetiously going
because also trends in comedy go in
cycles and so sometimes what is the
trend in New York is an old trend in
England and vice versa
Oh
yes so it's like and at that point in
time in England playing to the back of
the room was really hack but I didn't
realize you how tongue-in-cheek you were
being when you were saying hey uh maybe
I'll go over there I'd say that like a
[ __ ] means [ __ ] annum and a cigarette
i I yeah and I was trying to tell you oh
I thought you were doing the plane to
the back of the room thing and I was
trying to warn you my god I wouldn't do
that that's kind of you and I would
[ __ ] like miles away for the rest of
the time when I like yeah this should
have been an easier communication there
yeah I wound up going over recently I
did two in London and one in Manchester
was just incredible
loved it I did I open and close twice
twice because with chip you know with
the fact cigarette thing they went
bananas both times
[Laughter]
before we brought someone up because
that would have been County people can't
follow that but no I know it was it was
uh it was tough Jim when you went to
England he just did he was doing 15
minutes and then like you said wait a
minute you know look I got to go but you
look I'd love to do the [ __ ] bit no he
doesn't go out a gay guy to say the word
[ __ ]
there you go then a guy in a wheelchair
why do I suppose he doesn't go over
that's really like wrong and mean yeah
ground upon I see you know I under by
about 30 seconds like just close to 30
seconds under I was like I didn't want
to start a new one right right that's
good of you
yeah smart it was very strange because
I've never told the story out loud
before and I've never being able to tell
it in the you know what's the story do I
start on Friday
yeah I'm asking how long I could go fast
okay
till the version I told on the night no
internet 45 minutes just kidding could
that would imply that you went really
short in a natural fact night Savannah's
New York has taught me is [ __ ] me it's
water war funny heat so I come to the
gym yes in actual fact by the way such a
British the Aussie says that a lot an
actual fact that's a really British I've
been living there a long time I mean he
has been saying that that's why the only
person I've ever heard say that is Ozzy
Osbourne is getting launched I'm Ozzy as
ridden I'm super [ __ ] Ozzy I'm okay
ridden I oh yeah I'm like uncouth white
where do you where do you live in
England I live on a farm in the middle
of smack bang in the middle of the
country okay
smack bang why I would like to go out
there and one more time what town do you
live in I can't say the village because
sometimes I get death threats but I can
say the town what's the town it's a new
Bambury which is between London and
Birmingham Alton when I was a kid
get the [ __ ] out of here James Walton on
Thames look could you on Ashley Drive oh
that's right
quit bragging how long have you been
there I was only there for years oh no I
started out there in 1990 and then moved
to Melbourne between 92 and 94 and then
I moved back in 94 oh okay so you been
there for a long time yeah and then kind
of like all over is what we just want my
accents all over the shop there were the
Brits [ __ ] on the Aussies absolutely
we're scum oh yeah yeah which is weird
like so they didn't like when I get you
know get here and then like guys [ __ ]
burr kept the go and listen to it he is
hard [ __ ] Benny Hill over here and
I'm like
[ __ ] yeah check was there a Nintendo
Ronny was like did he just say Benny
Hill to me and he's like and then Ronnie
went oh all he's a big UFC Fan not a
very funny addition I just wanted to
toss that in I can't believe anyone
showed interested that marks a
professional market should we get a
person of color in here to do the n-word
part of your he's sitting next to one
that was the weird thing is melody
Mottola before it got applause breaks
it's like and big laughs where I wasn't
expecting him yeah to the extent where I
actually cut the story so short
come because because no asteroid don't
want to take the [ __ ] piece I mean I
heard from the guys in the theater not
that short at all really heard the crowd
took a piss that's a strange that the
end of the story just appeared and you
kind of learn that here as well that
when everyone's doing crushing tens yeah
and every was amazing you're so used to
in your head the beginning in the middle
and the end of the bit and a structure
of 20 minutes that it's hard to actually
go like all that gotta laugh buh-bye
mm-hmm and so but now I'm learning that
that sometimes just you know what if I
can't shave the bed enough get there's a
laugh and a clap I can [ __ ] off yes and
that it also trains you to have that
many jokes in your bits as well
anytime you know what I mean I chopped
quite a few that night we just kind of
go that's a good luck no it was a you
know really it was just a good feeling
oh just the right amount of laughter
good man yeah really good it wasn't it
wasn't too much you didn't go that long
no I did my twelve I talked to a lot of
people at the stand and the cellar like
a lot of audience members and they all
flew in for the Patrice Bennett it's a
lot of people do it was actually a woman
I know I'm guessing she's still here
from she's from Australia actually she
came in for the benefit
there's a few British comics as well
that for me that flew in Wow and they
said we're in the audience got the
British comic sir people British comics
ha but they still gone to that year's I
remember I went like three years ago and
then comics are in the audience so it
was my audience like oh yeah I mean lots
of comic years ago yeah I can't
comprehend that like I saw Keith
Robinson backstage I'm on you on and and
Grier was there and it's a big thing
like I really honestly genuinely thought
it would be remiss to not tell a story I
thought it would be rude you will you if
you cut out a few of your jokes before
the jerks we're gonna get the laugh in
the applause breaks they were I
literally did two [ __ ] one-and-a-half
bits what I would consider to be one and
a half bids the crab was that [ __ ]
great
mmm and I was like [ __ ] that's gotta go
that's gotta go that's gotta go and I
like have my glasses off because they're
so you see us Becky they are and I look
like a bit of a pedophile Yeah right and
there was just a couple of things I have
to do that you needed to see my eyes I
felt you didn't see - I'm standing there
without my glasses on not looking at the
clock I know I know I see three minutes
and it's 30 seconds uh-huh and then I'm
like oh [ __ ] I've gotta go then you wait
another 20 Patrice's ma'am up on stage a
factor in front of everyone so what's
the story what's the story
mark wish comment good yeah I can't keep
up with the IDH Deeping markers a little
mark did annoy users a little bit now
yeah you're very easy to get along with
oh thank you yeah delicious voice by the
way great voice so good it almost feels
like you're putting it on and then you
meet you in real life like it's in a
cartoon are you accounting no no good
[ __ ] you no Archer or something no I
wish I would love to any voiceover if
you're out there please everything you
all know enema you have a good voice I
would kill but I think my act they hear
my act and they freak out why they start
to mix are you listening right sarcastic
Fox Oh sarcastic Fox over here ball
grapefruit
sarcastic Fox oh great proofs is good
yeah yeah smartest man in the world well
that's a short version of the story
right okay 998 renew Castle I started
this the other day so wait the pictures
painted New Castle is this when you got
the first applause which was no I wanted
to put the ricer over because he's been
so lovely the whole time what no no she
was like when guys go over there I help
them translate I say yeah it's um Joe's
a sloped shouldered crud he has the
record amount of lost money in Edinburgh
I swear to God yeah that's a turn I know
that's at nine thousand pounds which is
what 15 make a little a break even he
lost nine girl why you put your own
money up yeah people know people whose
money all the time but he didn't do the
free fringe it's changed now the free
fringes where it's punk rock aha
and it's funny I understand now as well
when you guys talk about like I think
that kind of dude theme shows there yeah
and I was in a storyteller show the
other night before you I realize that's
what you guys mean by let a theme
because you go to a storyteller show and
I would like them off the podcast isn't
yeah and it was like the crowd should be
like clicking fingers and [ __ ] right no
I lost the money I don't understand
nobody so he puts the money up for his
shoes yes you rent the room and then
nobody shows the pays admission you see
the words like boring imaginable
oh sure he's had a little theater I
think was unlikable
yeah something like that it's probably
fun he said it smaller by the end he
knew he was gonna go home and I think I
came and saw him and went mate you'll
find out more about who you are in front
of doing an hour in front of three
people than you will 300 was really
three people though I was against number
there I think that's not up to six
recently but when I started there was
the average number was three four DeRosa
or in general shows because there's
three thousand chosen oh that's right
it's literally 24 hours it's not
literally 24 as the name is pretty close
probably about 20 hours for how long a
month I'm on my way and it's grueling as
[ __ ] yeah that's why he shows everyday
though you do your show and then you do
several light shows to try and plug it
you do like 18-hour days way that's
grueling as [ __ ] I talked and you got a
flyer you got a paper you got a bark I
tell you the whole thing took two Kyle
Kinane and he said the hardest part is
you go to the same room every night oh
you know you can't do you can't say call
without doing his voice can you do
console yeah he just said and that's
true when you think about it like you
know you go you know when you're at the
yucca MUPs in dick town you're just like
all right three nights I'll get through
it but imagine 30 yeah you know same
walk down the stairs say more scrutiny
than you've ever had in your [ __ ]
life it's exam time and they were using
there's like a there's like university
so well they really have small crowds
are huh no no they have huge crowds as
well unless you're and you know Jimmy
Carr I make money over you mmm telly
really you go as long as you want he's
so we'll see all right you're a little
saucy this morning yes I got such a
great voice it doesn't even feel
insulting there's nothing to Reiser in a
name that's good like it's like it's
like it's like a pet right charming
smile too much kind of a little fun
smile it's got a right a fun which is
fun and I'm very non-threatening right
just so much darkness under so what
happens right now paint the picture were
dead milling okay
19:19 alright so first up we meet 1998
we're in Newcastle which is like the
north of England it's like a port town
there's only white people scary blue
unintelligible fighting more than a seer
in Utopia
yeah the the applause break was that I
believe it's still away because I did
that and Damon attributed to [ __ ]
DeRosa and it's funny you guys are like
the WWE Universe is why you say the name
of a wrestler right please yeah so I
went yeah it was divisive Atari to say
that you didn't but there was to know
that the comedians are just right in the
bits back yes it's on top of the noggin
and so the thing is you need a bit of
context for this is and forgive me if it
now sounds practice because I told it
the other day here but black guys in
America don't know what their name means
in England hmm
so there's my really super [ __ ]
middle-class white English names that
don't know it I daresay the example I
gave was Ian Edwards yes
and he goes Jaime in Edwards and as a
foreigner you try not to laugh at his
[ __ ] face because what no you know
are you [ __ ] right I mean you knew words
no mate Ian Edwards is like a British
dude in a tweed jumper who makes his own
jam you know as a [ __ ] hanky right
Toby jugg and as a recipe for chutney
and then so this is killing a shitty
ramp for this [ __ ]
so the so when I see Patrice O'Neal on
the list that I'm living with Patrice
O'Neal for two weeks I'm expecting a 450
500 so I get into flat and there's a
six-foot four black bloke fat guy in all
directions
looking like Garfield barely looking up
at me right just like [ __ ] so like I
don't exist really kind of snooty [ __ ] I
don't right Edna said all right my name
don't on Brennan against pepper chase
and I was not expecting that noise to
come out of that head yeah right and so
I didn't try not to crack up laughing
and I said alright what's the running
order tonight [ __ ] I don't know but
I'm the headliner
and we don't have a headliner system you
don't introduce yourself that way mm-hmm
like it's a people kind of you know are
all kind of on a par and I said really
and I was like well how long you been
goin and he goes I mean go Nate no I've
been gone 10 so how about we go to the
club and see what the [ __ ] happens oh it
was maybe maybe six and eight right so
anyway we get to the club turns out he
is closing and I'm hosting but because
he hadn't even looked at me right he'd
barely introduced himself to me and I
thought like [ __ ] we stuck in a [ __ ]
house together for two weeks yeah I do
every [ __ ] County Peter Kay thing I
can before I bring him on I folks I'd
love to stay on I got to go first time
you met him and then at his once he's
dead you go to his show Patricia's to go
over your time just was not known to be
a clock honor to this all-white crowd
right and this [ __ ] unintelligible
scary [ __ ] blue people like they're
hard not [ __ ] they're Jordi's of
ruffer's guts yeah and you can't tell
whether this being friendly or picking a
fight they've got that Khan accent and
so go lazy urban Patrice O'Neal say
nothing about him he walks out the place
[ __ ] cracks up laughing and like
pointing at him laughing just Wow and
then he says in the very high-pitched
voice this him and she it is it and the
place cracks up even more and [ __ ]
just is he enjoying it or is he playing
no he's [ __ ] baffled he has no idea
interesting and then we because we were
living together for two weeks this
happens every night right every night
Wow
and he's like in the first after three
days that's right he didn't even look
him look at me until he heard me [ __ ]
and because I use did a lot of ecstasy
in cocaine and he heard me [ __ ] one
night and it was like a four hour
session the girl was coming and I come
out of the [ __ ] room
I used to be very pretty the room in the
towel I could sweat pools I know there's
a radio this is terrible I probably
won't do the face justice but it was
something glasses have come up paint the
picture the glasses are all and the face
was something like an exasperated Don
Knotts perronnette [ __ ] vagina up
nice and then he won his respect [ __ ] um
five star is this technically a story
about Patrice he wouldn't even look at
me until then right right and obviously
you're wondering how the [ __ ] do we like
break that barrier then we get on
famously would turns out that we love
I showed us oh yeah should stress after
I give him the shittiest intro ever he
goes and then he he proceeds to do the
best 45 minutes of stand-up I've ever
[ __ ] seriously like the extent weird
like you know when you hear a song and
you know it's gonna be your favorite
song I like had what must have been 85%
recall of his material I rang my mates
and was just like all the bits that
[ __ ] kick and the lady on the subway
the yes the pepsi-cola rapist yes see
the favorite my favorite was the one who
like I need an [ __ ] or nothing but
standing the bus stop next to get some
dude and he's like it was a you know I
never said you standing guy hey when you
punch that guy in the head alright had
[ __ ] oh my god did he mention how
much Jordi's love that as well oh just
that was my favorite [ __ ] bit and
this is a go six years in or something I
he was exactly so I'm not going I'm they
gonna bite and I'm gone by the way you
[ __ ] clothes right I'm ready
and he came off and I went might you're
one of the best and have some of them
[ __ ] seen in my life that was [ __ ]
amazing and and so that was the first
bit of the bridge second bit of the
bridge was I made of when we come five
times and he heard it yeah it does it
does that does strike me as really what
you wanted to do is you had twenty five
hundred people and you were like
me tell you how this wasn't in the story
last night I had old do you believe he
just brought it out for this you said
you want him to longer version of the
story I liked it that was did you like
that story I did finished neither would
any Wow mark you know jack shot Jim way
to steer the ship today we don't have to
when do you leave the stage uh Monday oh
you are gone again we got on famously we
had loads in common right
we like overanalyze things and also he
wouldn't go outside in New Castle
because he was scared because it was all
white people then I explained it's
because there's no black people there is
because that black people don't wanna
live in New Castle once he found that
out it was like a kid in a candy store
and he went he killed everywhere he went
interest everywhere and he was just like
it because well he was like you got to
understand in America when I go to a
state where there's no ends it's because
they hate ends right cuz you know what
you're saying but you don't say yeah you
said the word a lot dealer no when I was
talking to you yeah privately yeah Wow
well we were driving at the time yeah
yeah but the capture no one knew like
what address I was so so yeah we got on
famously we have loads of covered blah
he's killing us cracking me up
everywhere we go that's where he comes
sits down at the cellar table he's all
bummed out and Apollo goes what's going
on what's wrong goes man I just went to
the doctor I found out I got 9 another
10 things to kill [ __ ]
[Laughter]